Hola buenos días Aquí en el parlamento
europeo se ha vestido de gala para
recibir al presidente Vladimir selenski
en videollamada también para hablar de
esta invasión de Ucrania como pueden ver
a mis espaldas la bandera ucraniana
ha hablado en un discurso prácticamente
improvisado ha recordado que el lugar de
Ucrania pertenece dentro de la Unión
Europea muy emotiva recordado todas las
vidas sascadas en estos cinco días de
conflicto como comentábamos habido una
gran ovación para tras escuchar a
celensky pero tras su tras su
intervención habrá una votación en que
se espera cabrona totalmente simbólica
han dicho que si bien el lugar de
Ucrania está en la Unión Europea es algo
que aún se debe discutir porque es un
proceso muy complejo ambos lo han
admitido pero sí que es cierto que hay
que tener una sangre fría cabeza fría y
poder hablar de ellos sobre realmente
esta posibilidad es todo un proceso que
hay que seguir pero si se cumplen las
condiciones la Unión Europea no se
cierra a ello En todo caso tanto
wonderle y como dicen que están abiertos
a hablarlo
que estás sanciones sobre Rusia tendrán
también por supuesto un impacto en
Europa le pregunto cómo se prepara el
bloque para poder contener todo esto
para estar preparado a estas sanciones
económicas que también van a afectar del
otro lado
Sí así es las acciones van sin duda
afectar también a la economía Europea de
hecho los ministros de economía y
finanzas se reúnen mañana de urgencia en
una videoconferencia para poder abordar
esta cuestión como afrontar el enorme
impacto que van a poder tener estas
sanciones va a haber planes de
contingencia para poder frenar esta para
poder fregar estas consecuencias que
pueden frenar también la recuperación
económica tras la pandemia de hecho la
comisión Europea de Confía en que con el
plan de recuperación de 750.000 millones
de euros de alguna forma se puede
mitigar
nuevos planes de contingencia
exteriores dijo que Europa debe aumentar
su capacidad de disuasión A qué se
refiere exactamente con esto
Sí eso se aburre ya ha dado un cero
discurso un discurso muy duro en que ha
hablado que hay que preservar la paz de
que para preservar la paz también Europa
tiene que estar preparada la Unión
Europea llevaba años en renqueando con
sus planes de
defensados que se puedan desplegar
rápidamente por territorio europeo para
estar mayor preparados y sobre todo que
haya una Unión de la defensa más fuerte
es decir que los países junto con la
otan los países europeos pueden estar
más preparados en Casos de urgencia